Finally, a use for that 20 million dollars stuffed in your couch.
The world's largest known white diamond will go up for auction in Switzerland this week...
...where it could eclipse the record 21.5 million paid for a colorless stone last year.
The 101.73-carat pear shaped diamond was cultivated last year at Botswana's Jwaneng mine,...
...co-owned by the government and De Beers.
The stone took 21 months to polish.
And the first-time buyer at the auction will be allowed to name it.
Whatever the diamond earns...
...the all-time record will likely remain with the much rarer colored diamond,...
..."Fancy Intense Pink," which nabbed 45.6 million in 2010.
For the peasants of the world without 20 million dollars tucked away,...
...the diamond will go on tour in New York and Hong Kong after the auction.